البدايه طبعا ستكون من التطورات الحاصله
في البرازيل حيث اعلن رئيس البرازيلي لويس
اناسيو لولا ده سيلفا تدخل امنيا اتحاديا
في العاصمه برازيليه حتى نهايه الشهر
الحالي بعد اقتحام انصار الرئيس السابق
جريربول سانارو مرافق مرافق السلطه
الرئيسيه للبلاد في برازيليا ووصف دا
سيلفا في خطاب مسيري شغب بانهم فشيونه
ومتعصبون وقال انهم سيعاقبون بقوه بقوه
القانون الكامله وكذلك سيعاقب مموليها
وقال الرئيس البرازيلي ان عده خطاباتنا
لبسونارو شجعت انصاره على الاقتحامات
مشيرا الى ان برازيليا شهدت قصورانيه
وقد افادت وسائل اعلام برازيليه باستعاده
قوات الامن السيطره على مقررات الكونغرس
والقصر الرئاسي والمحكمه العليا بعد
اقتحامها من قبل الاف من مناصرين الرئيس
السابق جرير بورسونارو واظهرت صور
المتداوله تحطيما انصار بولسونارو لغرفه
لولده في القصر الرئاسي وكذلك تحطيم مكاتب
البرلمانيين كما وقف متظاهرون على مقاعد
مجلس الشيوخ في السياق طلب بعض من انصار
بوسونار بتدخل عسكري لالغاء نتائج
الانتخابات هو اقالتي لولاده بدوره قال
وزير العدل والامن العامه فلافيودينو ان
ما وصفها بالمحاول العبثيه لن تسود
من سوف باولو ينضم الى هاندرسان الصحفيه
لمتابعه ما يجري في البرازيل اهلا بك
استاذ هاني هل يمكن اعتبار بانه ال
الاوضاع اصبحت اهدى الان في برازيليا
من قبل المتظاهرين اعداد كبيره من الشرطه
والرجال الامل وصلت بشكل كبير الى منطقه
وبدات بالسيطره واحتواء المتظاهرين همم
ولكن التداعيات السياسيه ما زالت مستمر
فقبل قلي الاعلى المتحده عامرارا بتوقيت
السكرتيره الامني الخاص في ولايه براسين
هو السيد
همم
ساعات بسيطه كتب على تويتر با اهو ضد كل
ما يجري من احتجاجا ولكن هنالك بعض الامور
التي قطر
باتفاق هذا ما يقولون طبعا في الصحافه
البرازيليه ان هناك اضيق التواصل ما بينه
وبين رئيس بوسوناريو المتواجد اين في
الولايات الامريكيه
بمثابه اتهام له
من النائب العام قبل قليل هذا الامر همم
الاجراءات الامنيه التي
يتبعها رجال الامن
المباني التي تم بحاره العادات كانت كبيره
جدا في الحقيقه ليست كما ليس كما حصل
الامر الامريكيه فكان من عدد
احدى الملكيه ولكن هنا الاعداد قد تصل الى
الالاف في الحقيقه
في برازيليا بالذات وهل هناك من تحركات
واحتجاجات في مناطق اخرى من البرازيل
ليست حجم الاحتجاجات والتظاهرات الموجوده
في احتجاجات بسيطه بعض المناوشات بين
المؤيدين واليسار ولكن ليست كما هو الحال
في البرازيل ولكن الظاهر من الامر
والتحقيقات التي سوف تنشري التي امر بها
الرئاسه
سوف تبين الحقيقه والتي يعتقد ان هذا
الامر
السيطره على المركز الاسود
في الايام التي كان سيتسلم فيها الرئيس
الجديد الحكم هل هذه الاجراءات الامنيه
مثلا خفت بعد تسلمه وبالتالي استفاد
مناصره وسونارو بالقيام بهذه التظاهرات ام
هذا يؤكد بانه من الممكن ان يكون هناك
تواطئ من بعض الاجهزه الامنيه
لفتح المجال امام هؤلاء المناصرين لبوت
سونار بالقيام بما فعلوا فيه في الساعات
القليله الماضيه
بالفعل البرازيلي شهدت خلال التنصيب
اجراءات امنيه
ملكه خوفا من حصول ما حصل اليوم بالفعل من
اشتباكات ومن تدخلات من حالات عنف في
المقر الرئيسي ولكن
اليوم كان من المقرر مسبقا ان يتم على شكل
احتجاجات وهذا ما يتم احتسابه في قانون
البرازيلي بانه مسموع لاي فرد ان يكون
الديمقراطيه ولكن ليس باليه العنف واليه
تكسير التي حصلت داخل
الصوره التي تم نشرها قبل قليل المباني
استاذ هاني يبدو باننا فقدنا الاتصال به
نحاول ان نعود اليه مجددا عدنا الى استاذ
هاني نريد ان نعرف ايضا بالنسبه لموقف
الجيش لانه انصار سونار وكانوا يطلبون من
الجيش بالتدخل وباقاله لولا ده سيلفا هل
هناك اي تصريح او اي موقف للجيش تجاه ما
حصل اليوم في برازيليا
الجيش
تصريح مباشر من قبل الجيش فهو يحافظ على
دوري كمؤسسه خاصه الدفاع عن البلاد كان
هنالك ظهور لعدد من العساكر الذين يقومون
بالعمل الامن لحمايه تم استقباله من قبل
الاعضاء
الناصريه للم
ساندتهم في اداء لوظيفه حمايه الاماكن
العامه التي تدفع للشعب الى الجيش همم
ياخذ موقف
الوسيط لا يتدخل بشكل مباشر لحسابه على
طرف اخر يمارس دوره القانوني حتى شرعيه
القانون والدستور في البرازيل هل هناك من
اي موقف لبون سونارو لانه في الايام التي
همم التي عندما اعلنوا فوزا لولا ده سيلفا
طبعا كان هناك ايضا رفض من انصار سونار
وكان طلب منهم بان يكون او يحترم
الديمقراطيه ويحترمه هذه النتائج هل اليوم
قام باي تصريح هل طلب من انصاره التوقف
عما يقومون به ام حتى الان لا موقف له هو
نحن نعلم بانه خارج البرازيل وهو في
الولايات المتحده حتى انه لم يسلم الرئيس
الجديد الرئاسه
بالفعل خلال هذه اللحظه ليس هنالك اي
تصريح مباشر من قبل الرئيس السابق
هو متواجد في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قصر البرتقال الخاص بتسليم الرئاسه كل
الرئيس سابق الى رئيس جديد هنالك بعض
المقاوله التي كانت
يتم تداولها في الايام الماضيه قد يتوجه
الى ايطاليا
الرجاء
الايطاليه وقد يبقى في ايطاليا طويله وذلك
خوف ملاحقات قانونيه قد طالب نتيجه سوء
ادارتها لملف الكرونه والانتسبب الوفاه
100.000 من البرازيل اذا حاله
من الفوضى السياسيه
اليوم كان طبيعه شخصيه لهذا الشخص دائما
ما كان يتصدر وسال التواصل الاجتماعي في
حدوث ايامك لغايه اللحظه لم يصدر منه اي
همم رساله او اي تويتر في دائما
ولكن من المتوقع كان ممكن المسيح الذي
يستخدمه
بعض
الخاصه من خلال السوشيال ميديا لكي يستنكر
هذا
على كل حال استاذ هاني اسمح لي ان تبقى
معي
سنتوقف مع بعض ردود الفعل الدوليه على ما
جرى اليوم في برازيليه ومن ثم اعود اليك
اذا المشاهدين في سياق ردود الفعل الدوليه
لما حصل اليوم في برازيليا قال الرئيس
الامريكي ان الوضع في برازيليا موشين
وكانت واشنطن دانت اي محاوله لتقويه
الديمقراطيه في البرازيل وقال مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جيكسوليفان ان
بلاده تدين اي محاولاتنا لتقويد
الديمقراطيه في البرازيل باريس اصدرت من
جهتها بيانا عبرت فيه عن ادانتها لممارسه
العنف ضد مؤسسات الديمقراطيه البرازيليه
كما عبر ايمانويل ماكرون الرئيس الفرنسي
عن دعمه للرئيس المنتخب واحترام المؤسسات
اما رئيس المجلس الاوروبي سالم في تغريده
عن ادانته المطلقه
لاقتحامي مقر السلطات الرئيسيه في
البرازيل
اعود مجددا الى صحفيه هاني الدرسان ينضم
الى مجددا من ساو باولو استاذ هاني هذه
الردود الفعل الدوليه الى اي حد ايضا تعطي
دعما لرئيس لولا دا سيلفا ب- ااا
بتوقيف هذه التظاهرات او لتوقيع او اعاده
استتباب الامن في برازيليا وباقي المدن
التي من الممكن ان يحصل فيها تظاهرات مناه
له
رساله رسائل ايجابيه كبيره جدا من اغلب
دول العالم تدعم الشرعيه وتدعم القانون
وتدعم الديمقراطيه في البرازيل في حقيقه
الامر تلك الدول او جميع الدول التي اصدرت
بيانات كانت على قطيعه لمده اربع سنوات مع
البرازيل خلال
فكان هنالك مشاكل سياسيه خارجيه كبيره
للبرازيل سواء مع الصين سواء حتى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ومع اوروبا
السعداء بعوده العلاقات الطبيعيه الخارجيه
للدول الدول مع البرازيل وكان يوجد ثقه من
المقرر ان يقوم بزيارته خارجيه اول زياره
كانت مقرر له ان يخرج مباشره الى
الارجنتين بعد ايام قليله اليوزر رئيس
الارجنتين وثم كان سوف يتوجه الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لحد هذه اللحظه لم يتم
الغاء الخارجي او من جوله خارجيه للرئيس
سيلفا لكن الساعات القليله القادمه سوف
تبين لنا مدى تمكن الحكومه من اعاده
السيطره على ال- ال- الصوره العامه في
البلاد وضبط الامل اعتقد العمليه قد تمت
بشكل ال- ال- الاشخاص المتظاهرين تراجعوا
عوده الى موضوع
من الدول كل تاكيد هذا سوف يعطي دعما
وشرعيه كبيره لحكومه دوله سيلفا وهو ا-
طبعا شخصيه محبوبه من دول العالم كيف له
وقت يعني كان رئيسا
لدورتين التاليتين في البرازيل وكانت جمعه
على علاقات سياسيه قويه مع الكثير من
الدول الاجنبيه
يعني كان هذا اول موضوع قال بان البرازيل
ستعود الى الحضن الدولي والى علاقاتها
وخاصه بموضوع المناخ وموضوع غابات
الامازون شكرا لك من سوفاوله
درسنا الصحفي للمشاركه معنا اليوم في هذه
التغطيه الخاصه بالتطورات الحصله في
برازيليا شكرا لك